100 days ago i made an investment that
pays me 3 300 per day in profit off of a
single deal that was struck and i told
you about this at the beginning of the
deal um what was going to happen and so
i wanted to do this as kind of a part
two um of what actually happened in
actuality
for those of you who don't know me my
name is alex from ozio and
acquisition.com uh it's a portfolio of
companies that's about 85 million a year
i have absolutely nothing to sell you
the reason for this channel is because i
know a lot of people are broke and i
don't want you to be one of them all
right so one of the things that i like a
lot is hard money lending a big fan of
it it's private lending which is
basically like you are the bank and the
reason i like this is because you can
determine the deal structure which means
that you can create the upside and the
downside and then it's up to the other
party of whether or not they want to
accept that
and that's valuable because if you can
control a lot of the variables and you
can you can mitigate downside risk which
if you've heard any of my stuff the
ultra wealthy out there it's not about
trying to hit their upside like
everybody who's poor buys lottery
tickets because they only think about
upside but they don't think about
downside everybody who's rich who
doesn't do that because they understand
downside risk and how getting rich is
about really just making fewer mistakes
and letting time become
an ally rather than a liability using
time as an asset rather than something
that is working against you what i'm
going to do is i'm going to outline the
deal structure of what we agreed on um
and then what happened and then there
was one really curious thing that
happened that was actually awesome and i
think was probably the biggest takeaway
from me and hopefully
for you in this process big picture here
this was a two and a half million dollar
note all right so i wired two and a half
million dollars in cash to a buyer all
right and the buyer
went to buy a building
out of uh foreclosure all right so they
had a
334 unit which if you're like holy cow
house of 334 unit building two and a
half million hence the reason i was
happy to do the deal all right it was
also in a war zone like the police
officers don't even go here um this was
a deal in memphis and so it's 334 unit
building all right it was it was
basically condemned there's squatters
drug dealers you know all sorts of stuff
right and so here here are the here are
the risk factors right which is what if
i don't get the money back right which
means that i would have a building and
then how can i make sure that i get the
money back all right so the first layer
of defense here is guarantees all right
so both of the buyers these two two
people um personally guaranteed the
money all right and they had net worths
in excess of two and a half million all
right so we had that going for us times
two
next the building itself
we have the value right which the
question is well if it was condemned and
all that kind of stuff do we know what
the value is like is it really worth two
and a half million dollars would you
ever be able to sell it good question so
we had uh three offers already on the
building
for between 5 million
and 5.6 million so an offer is one thing
right but is there another level we can
have there was actually somebody put
earnest money down meaning that they
they had made the offer and it was
accepted and they were going to put
money in the deal so there's earnest
money of 300k so they had said we want
to buy it it was these guys the 5.6 guys
right earnest money 300 000 in the deal
saying that as soon as you guys can
transfer the title over to us then great
all right and the last thing was was to
make sure that we were actually in this
sounds minor but this is how a lot of
deals get messed up that we were
actually on the title right so that
means that if for some reason we do not
uh we do not get repaid we are the first
uh the first you know the first people
who have
ownership or entitlement rather you know
titled uh uh to the property all right
so that there's no uh other liens
against the property that we're the only
ones um who are going to be uh receiving
the property if something went in
default right and so our cash was used
to pay off the last person who had a
lien on the home uh on the homes of the
building and then we took over that
position as preferred and so this was
kind of the deal structure all right now
this is how we got paid all right so
these are the payment terms so it was
four percent per month all right now
four percent times 2.5 million if you're
curious right dude to do is a hundred
thousand dollars
per month all right so i was making a
hundred thousand dollars per month for
the last three and a half months
for them to hold this money now after
the fourth month so for some reason they
hadn't done this deal in four months
which it was supposed to be done in 60
days which it wasn't so i'll talk about
that in a second right so if it was uh
if it was done in uh if it took four
plus months
the interest rate would double all right
so then it would go to 200 000 per month
all right because then it starts to
reflect that there might be more risk
here right so i need to start getting
compensated more for this all right on
top of that what we did was a two-month
minimum carry uh which basically just
means that uh even if they do the deal
in 20 seconds i still get two months of
carry which means minimum of 200k i'm
gonna get back for just risking the two
and a half million which means i'm
getting eight percent or whatever um no
matter what just for doing this deal so
that's the minimum of 200k because
there's a minimum two month carry all
right that's the key point here beyond
that
what happened is after uh this deal
ended up closing um here's what happened
so uh the individuals who did the deal
they flew out to see us and have a kind
of like a celebratory dinner this was
kind of interesting so they're like hey
your lawyer sent over the note um and it
looked a little light and i was like uh
what do you mean they were like well
uh you know we've had the we've had the
property for a hundred plus days now
right
and the note said 275k
and i was like huh and they're like yeah
i mean
that wasn't what we agreed on we agreed
on paying you more than that
and so this is so here's what happened
right so uh our lawyers messed up for
lack of a better term they just messed
up when they sent the uh the the loan
invoice for repayment at the end of this
and what was interesting is that this
individual because he is long-term
minded as well and also a height ultra
high net worth individual and this is
why i think this is probably more
valuable than the deal itself was like
yeah my lawyer saw it he was saying his
lawyer saw it and said yeah let's just
send the money like and you know
they made a mistake let's let's move on
right and save ourselves you know
almost 100 grand which i'll show you in
a second what the actual amount was and
he said ah man he's like now you can't
be my lawyer anymore and he was telling
me this story over dinner and it was so
funny because we both had this kind of
same
so the more deals you do with someone
there's a big five-letter word that
starts to occur which is trust right the
more times you lend someone money the
more times they pay it back as agreed
upon right and especially if you have an
instance where they have the opportunity
to screw you over where most people
would
especially if they think that they that
you'll that you won't find out which we
might not have found out but the thing
is i might have also looked at these
notes a while later and been like like
if i had free time and been like this is
off what is this right and so anyways he
caught it his lawyer caught it his
lawyer said to go forward with it
anyways he chose not to and to bring it
to our attention and so we obviously are
not going to use our lawyer anymore he's
not going to use his lawyer anymore
because our guys made a stupid
boneheaded mistake and that's what we
pay them for is to not make these
mistakes and double check these things
right and his made an ethical error
right so mine was an error on skill his
was an error on ethics and if you
remember my how i pick mentors and
vendors video i talk about the three
circles right you have the skill you
have the the ethical component then you
have the hard working component and so
both these guys
worked hard but they didn't have this
one of them didn't have the skill and
the other one didn't have the ethics so
this is what ended up happening all
right so 275 was the deal instead uh we
did the we had it was a hundred and
something days or whatever so we had
300k
plus
33 33 33
per day
um until the deal was closed all right
and so it ended up being like 350k or
something like that with decimals right
that we got paid back plus the 2.5
million all right so we got to check
back for 2.85
million
and we have trust
which is the most valuable thing that
you can have right and so this is this
is ultimately one of those currencies
that people do not understand who are
new to business is that trust is the
most valuable thing i mean we were
talking about this over dinner and he
was like you only get one name you know
what i mean you only get one you only
get one name you only get one uh
reputation see if i can not get the sign
of my eyes here you only get one and uh
you know we're obviously you know hoping
to do bigger and bigger deals with you
guys is uh you know we earn more and
more trust and we can do you know 10
million deals 50 million deals um and
we'd rather have partners that we know
we can rely on and so it goes both ways
and so
anywho uh this was a very valuable
experience for me in two ways one
obviously because the the whole deal
worked out uh and for those of you who
are like why don't you run a mastermind
it's like because i could just move the
money and not do anything and make
almost 400 that is why i'm just being
transparent with you guys like that's
why i don't sell anything on the channel
that's why the the the trainings we have
on acquisition.com are free for all
entrepreneurs and the book is 99 cents
you can get it on amazon because i just
want everyone to win so anyways this is
the deal a lot of people like no one
taught me how to do this stuff so it was
me just trying to figure this out as i
go um so hopefully you can think through
some of these variables if you ever get
in that situation
and then also um just a side note here i
do have to pay 50
in taxes on this and so that's why you
need for me i have to have really high
returns on any kind of private lending
because uh the the i have to realize
those gains right and they're not
capital gains to regular income and so
uh when you have that i'm actually only
making 175 after after taxes on this
deal which you know in terms of
percentages on on on my original i still
want to loan that money out again you
know again this year uh so that i can
still get at least you know 10 or 20
return on it that's the big deal in
terms of the money stuff uh the bigger
deal was the trust um and the value of
having trusted partners uh because they
are worth their weight in gold and uh
you know we should only be so lucky to
have a handful of people that you can
trust throughout your business career
and uh you know my hope is that from
this channel that you are one of them in
terms of uh in terms of yourself and
then also maybe you know you grow your
business to three or five or ten million
a year and then you let us invest with
you so we can help you grow out more so
anyways uh keep being awesome mostly
nation love you if you enjoyed this
video hit the subscribe button if you
didn't enjoy the video love you anyways
and i'll see you guys in the next vid
keep being awesome lots of love bye